yeah I like to start my videos in a
really medium note hi guys I'm here with
Andrea Russett oh yeah she just was a
guest on the podcast not too deep if you
go over to soundcloud.com slash not too
deep with grace you can listen to the
whole interview that we just had I
learned so much about you possibly a
little too much and while she was here
recording the podcast I thought we'd do
a challenge together for the YouTube
today we're going to play the blindfold
youtuber drawing challenge we have a
list of youtubers and the list of
activities we will choose each round one
youtuber one activity will blindfold
ourselves and for about a minute we will
draw this youtuber doing an activity and
we have a very special guest judge that
will be joining us in a little bit our
guest judge is going to come and try and
guess what who that is
and what activity they're doing oh and
if he correctly guesses the youtuber
we've drawn we get a point if he guesses
the activity and YouTube we get two
points if he only guess is the activity
we get one point and so we're gonna do
the where you see what happens after
three rounds okay so we're gonna pick
our youtuber judge and I love to see so
and now wait to pick an activity what
okay oh god oh that couldn't happen in
real life right on your mark get set
lose friends okay shoot is my grand play
down I don't know what I'm doing
it seems good I've already locked up all
night facial awareness or anything 15
seconds oh wow that would have fast this
is a thing I just now make alright boys
I'm so I got a plan and the plan the
plan is disappeared
yeah oh god I panicked and it's gonna be
way wrong in the look at him a man will
look at our stuff okay it looks like it
oh please welcome our guest judge
Mitchell Davis oh the crowd goes was
very exciting high energy entrance
oh man um okay yeah there's a lot
happening
yeah there's I like your color use this
is this is Tyler Oakley on a surfboard
Oh
half of it is it it's Tyler Oakley but
he's snowboarding oh how did you get
that are you kidding at the boat I
behave that's yeah yeah but I'm my depth
perception shoe he's just going so fast
all this clothes are you okay it looks
like so much why don't you open like
someone won an award um is okay is that
it does have a very elephant is supposed
to be an R that it oh man that is so
Ella winning an award Oh God does that
count
okay I guess a calorie is Oh Ellen
winning an Oscar are you kidding oh my
god we're so good at art Wow
this is a hidden talent okay well now
get out of here we're going round to
round two let's pick our youtubers good
yeah oh boy okay yeah oh this is gonna
get really juicy and our activities oh
yeah I can do this look okay it's coming
on your mark get set go
a lot better so chair
time are we looking at our drum wow I'm
impressed with my oh that is not bad at
all that is a thing that happened
we've improved would you say that yeah
is that something that you're gonna hear
this objective I don't think you're
gonna get my [ __ ] into these no there's
some animals I want to say there's a
horse and someone playing tennis
that's jennamarbles playing racquetball
those are her dogs tell me that's not
right it's right but it is not at all
okay
yes law that says glozell to me because
it's all green I like this is maybe more
stressful for mister than it is for
either bus no man I'm feeling the stress
right now siliceous that that is that is
glozell cutting the grass out front is
absolutely wrong
I know the resume construction has I
thought you're just throwing up shall we
okay okay and then an activity oh this
is gonna be good
that's gonna be a real interesting photo
okay this is Ready Set draw
your game time
alright let's look at our ride round
drawings I am so impressed with myself
now are you kidding me okay
yeah okay here we go you have a melting
Sun smiley face and then a normal red
Sun Thomas and now I know you're trying
to find Kardashian's ass right here this
is Hannah trapped in a canoe in the
middle of two mountains jennxpenn
climbing a mountain uh mountains done
got the men got the mountains real good
okay yours is really good dude I know it
myself so it's someone in the water
someone on a boat
it's a youtuber sailing in the you
should pay attention to the detail the
youtubers tail elusively purple with
pigtails Connor that's what it is
Connor on a sailboat Heaney grew his
hair out it's a castaway interpretation
and amidlifecrisis grew his hair out
fine he was trapped Ryan I tried and
yeah that's that's Connor on a boat you
know the the details of the arrow
pointing a turret or I thought you meant
that they just left land
yeah I thought they were on a fast boat
maybe and you were trying to know show
that they just like skidded off and help
it out feel like I don't know if there's
an actual winner in this competition
because it's me
oh we're tied yes oh we're tied there
actually is it there's no way to low
position
can I please create a lightning round
right now yeah we're gonna be drawing as
fast as some furiously as possible all
right and uh would you guys as soon as
they start I can start guessing that's
correct
great I'm so excited okay ready uh-huh
set go okay hey Gracie's got a solid
start
we got a woman we're gonna women with
big lips are you hiding
I'm trying butterfly no no no no an
elephant scissors someone cutting with
scissors and they're in a red dress
that's someone cutting there this is
someone with the green thing in their
hand that's I know who that is
I don't know who that is uh that is that
is maybe cutting your own hair that is
uh you're doing something from The
Wizard of Oz which i think is actually
kind of nice you're going against the
grade and you're just drawing something
pretty music so they're singing they
sing they sing who who sings that is a
musician that's like jamming out so all
over the kids are the sprinkleofglitter
when I can't excuse me that's a penguin
no no okay I would start this over
they've got flippy hair is that is that
Tyler Oakley on it I know that and
beyond an elephant is that it's chained
Austin on nothing no should we just
declare that Mitchell loses and Andrea
no way think a song like that so right
hey I'm so embarrassed so oh I come on
then Oh whistle oh come on that's really
good I wasn't even supposed to be in
this video so much of the hair flip man
I think we learned one thing
and Mitchell Davis sucks at guessing
YouTube and Andrian are really good at
drawing absolutely that's one thing we
can take away is that uh why I don't
know that there's any winners or any
losers other than just me no more
Mitchell Sealy losers well Thank You
Andrea for being here
thank you and thank you Mitchell for
allowing me to force you into an
exploitative position uh really good you
can keep your chair yeah don't forget to
go over to soundcloud.com slash not your
deep with grace to listen to the full
podcast agree with Andrea and make sure
you go over to her youtube channel and
check out her videos that are how much
more resolution in this video I don't
know it's always so interesting every
time I tweet out like any questions for
ex person huh the people that responded
to wanting to ask you questions a lot of
them are perverts I'm just gonna put
that out